Hey everybody, welcome
to the content video for
section 5.9, Searching
Sequences. So like list sorting,
list searching is also a
very, very complex topic
and it gets very complicated with a
lot of different searching algorithms
and algorithms that take huge
amounts of computing power.
None of that is what we're gonna
cover in this content video.
This one's also going to be
kind of quick. there's two I
guess terms or functions I want
you to know one is index and
the other is in or not in so
what we're gonna do is do a
couple of examples with that
so this is the searching okay
so let's say we have a list of
I don't know favorite colors.
And we'll get a little bit more variety
this time. We'll do red. Whoops,
should probably put the
quotation marks on color. Yellow,
green, blue, orange, orange,
and we'll throw in pink.
Those are all the colors.
There's no other colors.
So what I would want to do is
maybe if, let's say this list
is massive, like thousands
and thousands and thousands of
colors in a data set or in a
list, and I don't know if a
particular color is in that list,
so I want to do a search on the
list to find it. So what I
could do is I could say print
out favorite colors and I want
the index for the color green.
And what this will do, I used the wrong
key. I'm bad at typing today, y'all.
That's wrong too. Hang on. Okay.
What this will do is it will return
to me the index of the color green.
So it's at the second index.
And again, imagine with me
that this is a huge list with
so many things in it, and it's
going to return to me the first
instance of that color. So
I don't have to worry anymore.
Green is in this data set.
What if I threw another green on
the end so green it would still just
return to me the first index of where
that item shows up so that's one
way to search a list um it is case
sensitive so if i was to type in
capital g green for example and run
this code it will not find green
in the list so we get a value error
all right so let me switch that
back okay the other one is the in
operator whoops sorry that's some That's
not where I wanted. So the in
operator looks for a true false in if
something is in a list or in a
sequence. So if I was to say, if green
in fav colors, that's, yeah, that's
definitely what I wanted to do.
Okay, if green in favorite colors, print.
Green is in the list.
Okay, so you can see here that green is
in our list. What about capital G green?
Let's throw one else on here.
Okay, so that value is not on
the list. So the in operator
searches the list for that value
that we specify. If it finds
it, it returns true. If it does
not find it it returns false.
Similarly we can use not in and
not in looks for the opposite just
like with a boolean operator not
just reverses what we're looking or
the the truthfulness of the results.
So not in if normally that would
be true now it's false if it's
normally true it's now false so that
is very very complex list searching
simplified down to a couple of
methods and that concludes this
content video thank you for watching